it seems to me like you put in a lot of
years practicing stand-up comedy trying
to find your voice i got 20 years in
yeah and when things really clicked for
you is when you really got personal
right when you talked about your family
when you talked about your life growing
up suddenly you don't become a jokey
comedian you become a realist i stopped
being a character
and that's what i mean even with you and
and and radio you know there's a point
where you got to robbing you as well you
got to see people listen to us because
we're ourselves genuine there's and it
takes a long time to find that it
doesn't you don't you don't tap into
that and people that say they tap into
that in life [ __ ] yeah i tapped into it
at the later stages of my career when i
really started i stopped with the the
phony voices i stopped with the fake
stories i stopped and as you started
realizing that and you started to get
more real about your life uh you won a
lot of amateur contests you played
bigger and bigger clubs across the
country and is that how judd apatow
found you for that sitcom that you guys
put together well dave attell another
funny comedian man
dave said i want my manager to look at
you so through these associations you
come to the attention of the great jud
appetite right yes and you guys put
together a tv pilot north hollywood
north hollywood and you probably figured
this is it man i'm going to be on tv i'm
going to judge i made it you made it i
think it's over this is going to be my
ticket 25 000 check for the pilot i
called everybody look guys this is what
we gonna do i'm a first of all mom i'm
going to set you up
uh kenneth you don't do nothing i got
you just right now it's coming in and
did you go out and buy yourself a
mercedes or something yeah stupid the
first first of all did you have no
concept of twenty five thousand
yeah yeah i thought twenty five thousand
was the equivalent of twenty five
million
caught everybody
hey look don't nobody do nothing i got
us all calling friends that i grew up
with isn't that money i don't know how
fast that money went so you must have
been really in shock when the pilot
doesn't get picked up you're like well
this doesn't compute where's my 25 000.
do you know who was in the pilot with me
yeah who was independent amy poehler
right jason siegel myself judge reinhold
isn't that unbelievable
um rogan in there no rogan was one of
the writers with this can you imagine
that and that is supposed to be and
that's the horror of the television
business
you have that many talented people
involved and they can't get this pilot
the hand on talent that judd apatow has
had and still has it's unbelievable it's
unbelievable that was our circle back
then we're talking years ago me and
jason siegel lived together for the
pilot yeah i know and and that was
judd's suggestion to you he said i want
you guys for this pilot to live together
to actually move in together and really
get to know each other i guess that was
for some sort of familiarity he wanted
to convey because he played roommates in
the show so he wanted us to really have
that roommate field so can you imagine
here you are you move to l.a you figure
hey okay i'm gonna get my career going
i'm in the judd appetite thing i'm
living with jason siegel so we can
really know it because we're going to be
the new odd couple and
you're good
and that is the [ __ ] disappointment
in life i went through a period where i
was a pilot's virus any pilot that i
touched did not get picked up yeah i
mean and you start to think you start to
think no
i'm a real disaster here do you call
your mom your brother all the people you
bought stuff for and say listen i need
this money
back no you gotta take that long